there's not anything in the world that
is art today that wasn't originally [ __ ]
on by the prior art thing
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
podcast nation let me just say this very
simply this is one of the most selfish
podcasts in the history of the garyvee
audio experience
because i want to be able to have my
grandkids ask me what it was like to
know this gentleman
because there is
borderline 0.0 percent chance in my mind
god willing he stays healthy
um that
that he doesn't become one of the most
profound most important artists of this
generation
and it is my incredible honor to have
videnza tyler on the show
tyler how are you oh gary i'm doing
great i mean uh what an intro to the
show uh i don't know i mean you're
really setting a high bar there for me
uh but uh i'm sandbagging
yeah yeah
maybe lower those expectations just a
tiny bit uh but uh
no i'm i'm super excited uh
uh it's it's a real pleasure to get to
talk to you here today so let's let's
really go into nft art like that's the
punchline of this most definitely you
know obviously i have a lot of
entrepreneurs but i really really want
to go into
the history of you and this moment yeah
you know
for for people that see the title and
click it
you know that are really deep in our nft
world i'm gonna i'm gonna say it so you
don't have to because i know you're a
humble kid like you know it's very
difficult
for me to think of 10 artists
that have more of an opportunity to be
you know truly one of the names that
people talk about in 30 60 90 years i
don't think there's any confusion
for anybody paying attention that we're
in this moment right now where the four
fathers and mothers where the where the
you know i read boom
a couple some i don't read books and i
read
temporary art a couple five summers ago
four summers ago three summers ago i
can't remember now but mainly because i
wanted more insight to what i saw
happening in the sports card world okay
i can't believe
what happened because only a couple
years later nft world happens and all
and me mapped me not only reading that
book but googling my ass off about
going deeper on the little bit i already
knew about pollock or warhol
yeah yeah
you know yeah my uh my friend kevin rose
who i know is a big fan of your work
right
uh and i did a podcast yesterday we
recorded which will be coming out in a
couple days i don't know the timing you
can see this and he told me i had not
known this one i like this kind of stuff
that when canvas
first hit the scene
that people in the art world said that
wasn't real art
because real art had to be on a wall
yeah yeah yeah canvas could be damaged
and this and that right
it was all frescoes and church walls
before that right correct so humans
continue to make the same mistake this
is an art this is art and then that
becomes the art that's right
so i kind of uh i kind of honestly i'm
surprised like i thought we'd seen that
play out so many times that uh more
people would would kind of uh be looking
for that same thing to happen again and
it seems like uh nfts are just like the
latest incantation of that uh humans are
incredibly good at seeing the world
through their selfish frame or the frame
of their own insecurity yeah not from
the lens of history most definitely most
definitely yeah yeah so and
the nfts are it's just it's a neutral
technological platform on its own um
it's it's a sister system of record
keeping um there is a particular culture
that's associated with it right now but
uh
yeah to say in any way that uh real art
can't be uh
published as an nft sold as an nft you
know design as a as an nft in mind uh
seems pretty preposterous from where i'm
sitting at
me as well my friend and when people
listen to this podcast in 39 years
they'll be like wow they do so to that
point let's get into it yeah uh i you
know what i'm really excited about is
you're really one of those icons in my
mind so i think a lot of people are
about to be inspired to start uh others
are gonna be inspired to consider
um and most and others will be inspired
to collect your work or people like
yourself so
let's start with this how the hell did
you get to the place
in your opinion using using
candor not just don't be overly humble
why are you how did you get to a point
where you're sitting on my podcast yeah
community and i feel compelled to say
these things about you not because i'm
being nice because i want to be
historically correct right
right how'd we get here
uh you know i i asked myself that um a
fair amount but uh i i think
you know i think the most important uh
aspect by far is just the artwork itself
so you know most of my time has been
spent um working on my artwork um
refining that learning about
other artists
trying trying to spend as much time as
possible developing my work and making
it as good as possible and you know um
i did that for
you know a decade decade and a half
before nfts were even something that i
was looking at so
um
tyler that artwork was physical or that
artwork was 100 digital yeah so i
started out in in the physical realm so
i started out with traditional drawing
and painting and kind of uh paid my dues
so to speak learning all the kind of
traditional backgrounds and uh
graphic design and um
uh yeah about 20 2014 is whenever i
first
started working digitally and that's
when i started working with generative
art with algorithmic cards so this is uh
you know what i what i do today which is
i write uh programs that generate
artwork and
um so about about 2014 i started
experimenting with that and i got super
hooked on it i i felt like it was much
more interesting and much more
relevant to our to our time uh and to me
personally and so that's really what i
focused on since 2014.
uh i was
25 i think uh approximately
what year was i born 1987. so wait uh
you're gonna make me do math live on air
uh
yeah uh something close to that i'll
save you time 27 27 okay there you go
thank you
yeah um so spoken like a true artist by
the way um
uh
talk to like take me further back you're
born war
and what kind were you are we drawing at
five years old and into it give me that
yeah sure yeah i grew up in central
texas so close close to austin basically
suburbs around austin i've pretty much
lived here my entire life and
yeah growing up i always liked making
artwork i was not uh some some kind of
prodigy kid right so i was good but uh i
was not picasso making you know
incredible paintings at the age of seven
um but i was fortunate that uh my
parents you know uh got me into
uh painting lessons after school where i
was working with you know um
are either of your parents into art not
really my dad's a doctor and my mom uh
well she um
you know she raised us my my siblings
and i and uh she she did uh do some some
really amazing quilting which i think
has had has a stylistic influence on me
but uh no not not particularly creative
and they definitely didn't know about
like the art world and uh so i had i had
a pretty
average kind of um education along those
lines but uh yeah i started you know
getting books of like van gogh paintings
and things like that and it just really
really resonated with me and say again
siblings
uh yeah i have older brother who who was
kind of a self-taught hacker and that's
kind of how i got into programming and
uh
my my younger sister has uh
studied engineering um and has had kind
of an interesting life but not not
really artistic either so
um just me keep going
you start you know you're into painting
after school yeah
yeah i started doing things like copying
uh
van gogh paintings trying to like
recreate them um actually did some some
pretty good versions of that those
that's taught me quite a bit
yeah did a lot of this kind of um
semi-formal uh painting training and uh
when it when it came time for
uh college i i wanted to go to art
school but uh my dad was a little more
pragmatic he wasn't a super huge fan of
that for kind of obvious reasons and he
encouraged me to
go for computer science instead which i
had been doing computer science at high
school and and my brother was kind of
doing that so it made sense to me to do
that as a career and it was interesting
um so that's that's what i studied was
uh computer science at the university of
texas at austin and yeah start started
working as like a a programmer right out
of school
but art was what i was always working on
in my spare time and it's always what i
was thinking about long term and what i
felt uh kind of had the most interesting
challenges long term for me
something i wouldn't get bored with and
something that
felt felt a little bit more personal and
meaningful and uh so that's that's
really why i've been pursuing art i
think
i love that
so
this is so cliche and obvious how we got
here now based on that yeah but when
when do the gears really get going you
started talking about i want to go back
to it yeah
make sense you're programming
you're falling in love with art
literally
like when i first heard about generative
star stuff
um you know
12 14 15 months ago i was like
literally the person that i thought was
going to most win
in that was literally
the story that you just told of your
life
yeah
that's going to be for the kids that are
nerds
with tech they can do it yeah they code
but they have an artistic streak oh like
i always love when the technology comes
along that's made for a certain person
when that didn't exist before look at
your life you were jekyll and hyde
that you know you know bruce wayne
batman you had to live like these
different lives because they didn't come
together all of a sudden the blockchain
is at the right time at the right moment
generative art movement happens and
you're [ __ ] friends now yeah yeah
exactly i i felt like um i was just teed
up perfectly for everything that
happened with nfts in in 2021 especially
you know art blocks um
platform for uh
for creating generative artwork on the
blockchain right so the basic ideas you
you write the generative script itself
uh to the blockchain and then you
generate nfts uh from that script
directly and you can sort of prove that
the work that's coming
uh into the hands of the collector is
direct output from that script and so
it's a really uh powerful way
uh to to create generative artwork and
it creates a really uh interesting
artistic challenge as well like this is
uh
somewhat different from the type of
generative work that i and other
generative artists were making prior to
nft so it's actually really enabled a
new type of artwork and i think the
artists that have done well were ones
that um
maybe were were open-minded and had uh
that that kind of that kind of work
ready to go
um as soon as uh
you know these technologies around the
blockchain started to develop um and and
then it just as you saw it it took off
like crazy in 2021 it was just
like uh you know the curve went straight
up uh at a certain point and uh
yeah i feel i feel really fortunate that
i already kind of had my [ __ ] together
at that point
being empathetic to the crowd and and
you're saying some things that i can
follow along because i've been deep in
this last year and a half but you know
knowing that most haven't
talk us through we missed a pardon i'm
gonna go to it now to connect on where
you just went so now you're doing
physical
you're jekyll and hiding it blah blah
blah
and then you said 14 is when you started
going digital right why how and exactly
what were you making yeah okay so uh
2014 uh i've just been making
traditional work i've been doing a lot
of um you know a lot of studies a lot of
like figure drawing um kind of kind of
getting all the basics uh really solid
and i felt like my art was uh good but
it was very generic like it was very
generically good it wasn't really unique
to me
and uh some of the advice that i heard
for artists that that resonated with me
was that you really have to make it
personal you have to make the kind of
work that only you could make you have
to involve you know whatever special
elements of your life you can you can
bring to the table those are going to
make your artwork more personal and i
highly recommend this advice for for
every artist but for me that was
programming like that was such a big
part of my life and and it influenced
the way that i i really thought about
things so i knew i had to involve
programming in the artwork um
it wasn't exactly obvious how to do that
i had quite a few failed attempts of
like mixing math into hand-drawn things
but eventually i had the idea of you
know uh can i just write a program that
generates a painting and um i kind of
took the tools software tools that i had
uh cobbled something together and uh
what were the software tools you had
uh this was a matplotlib which is like a
scientific uh charting uh library you
normally use it to draw like graphs but
uh you can you can kind of finagle it
into making artwork yeah exactly so it's
kind of a hacky approach uh i didn't
know that there were better tools for it
at the time
but what were the better tools for it at
the time yeah so processing this is
something that casey reese
and ben frye put together and and um
it's really uh enabled enabled a whole
generation of uh of generative artists
to work
um
so generous
adore those guys oh absolutely they're
they're legendary um casey's been so
meaningful and so influential for the
space probably the most important
generative artist uh to date i would say
is casey reese
and uh and ben fry's still maintaining
processing so you know uh huge uh props
to to them for doing that um and that
that's a big that's a big reason why
generative art is also having this
moment um you know that
these people uh put so much time and
love into into creating these tools that
enabled a whole a generation of of
artists you know especially programmers
uh to to to be artists and to express
themselves
and um i think uh yeah i think it just
it really resonates with people right
now because uh
programming is so central to our lives
right now like even if you're not a a
programmer you probably spend at least
eight hours a day in front of a screen
interacting with software right these
are things that uh programmers have
constructed and so kind of the those
basic tools of code are what our whole
environment is is being built with today
so i think it's really really important
that artwork is also built with those
same things
and i think that'll just help to you
know kind of humanize our digital
environments help us to to have a
a better and more enjoyable uh
relationship with software if it's not
just all like written by you know amazon
and
facebook right like i want artists to be
able to fully utilize those same tools
and i think that's what's uh really
important uh about generative artwork
and other art forms that they work
directly with with programming and code
you think the historical artwork
felt that coding is too nerdy and two
ones and zeros and two
tech bro and [ __ ] this and big time
victim yeah so general of art started in
the in the 1960s
and man it got uh they went through some
hard time like uh really bad critical
rap people were [ __ ] on it left and
right i i think uh the reaction there
was that they felt like
some element of humanity was lost by
creating
yeah it's easy to see like maybe why
they they felt that but at this point
that feels like a really naive um
assumption right i would argue that 95
of the people listening to this podcast
right now who are incredibly
curious and open-minded and
entrepreneurial because
my podcast which is like i just know
that community
even for them i think that they can
easily feel the chemicals in their body
of why
well that's kind of weird like weird
like
write code hit enter and then there's
art like that feels i'm empathetic to
that i just don't agree yeah yeah yeah i
think it's i think um i think it takes a
mental uh shift a little bit right like
computers are
the most powerful and important tools
we've ever come up with um and and they
totally revolutionize everything and and
they enable
uh just so much more that we haven't
been able to do before and and and that
same thing applies to artwork like it
would be just such a waste if we didn't
create the best artwork we could by by
fully utilizing computers as well
they're just a tool in the in the hands
of the right artist they can make
incredibly beautiful things and i think
right it's really no different than
paint versus a pencil
like why is painting better than a
sketch
or vice versa it's not it's not yeah
it's not it's not i mean this has been
my biggest problem with the art
conversation
the hypocrisy is disgusting
like you will literally watch someone
talk about our eye of the beholder
they'll talk about why they love
something and then somebody brings
something completely different like
that's [ __ ] that's not art i'm like what
the [ __ ]
don't you understand that your thing was
[ __ ] on too
there's not anything in the world that
is art today that wasn't originally [ __ ]
on by the prior art thing absolutely
every single artistic movement every new
artistic technology like uh cameras
right cameras came out uh people didn't
think you could make real art with
cameras it took like decades for for
that to be accepted and now we don't
even think twice about that being a
possibility right so
um yeah i think i think people will feel
exactly that the same way about uh
generative art and uh ten years you're
still a young guy
very very young
and i'm listening to you talk and my
observation is the following i started
with this and now it's you're actually
in those shoes
do you have a and this is where i'm
going to need you to
you know like answer it actually and
don't be too humble do you actually you
know you've got some momentum obviously
you're like hey i got a lot more work to
do i respect all that sure but even
where you're at in the space now and you
and i can tell you know the timing of it
do you think like oh weird i'm going to
be 80
and 20 year old kids are going to be
like tell me what you like in the old
like like do you have a sense that
you're going down that path
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think so i mean i think
i think here's probably what's going to
play out is like the kids that uh that
are growing up seeing all this stuff uh
being made right even just the people
that are teenagers right now watching
this going on they're going to
absolutely uh dunk on my work in like
no time right like i'm going to be the
old
old fashioned dude before no time that's
right from a technology advancement
standpoint they're going to dunk on it
but let me give you an actual dunk on it
okay lebron james lebron james
would dominate
oscar robinson in basketball yeah yeah
because of the evolution of the human
right and the queen but i promise you
when lebron james through the last 20
years crossed paths with the big o yeah
the ring of the legendary status of it
and that's what's cool about the game
yeah absolutely that's right the
six-year-old today that will listen to
this in seven years yeah that will crush
you
yeah 18 years from like a
technical and did it
right she
will still always say
that you like that's what's so cool yeah
yeah exactly that's that's how i feel
about um all the predecessors right so
like people like uh casey reese and and
all the traditional painters that um
have have massively massively influenced
me i know i've been caught on this i'm
sorry to interrupt i've been hot on this
i like to give out roses more often
you've already done a little bit of it
just rattle off
some names
that you think deserve some googling
from the people listening right now
and and do they have nfts for people to
go discover and who do you think's
underrated as a pioneer that has nfts
that people because people love a good
little alpha that might be nice for the
community yeah okay okay
uh i mean the the alpha one person that
just uh came to mind is uh this artist
holger lipman who's uh he's a german
artist and he was making generative work
uh before i was he was one of the people
that i saw
um
uh
that really inspired me i think he has a
a great sense for for color and and for
form and rhythm and uh so he was making
really beautiful generative artwork that
that i saw when i was first getting
started and he talked about that how's
that spelled holger littmann uh
h-o-l-g-e-r and then lipman is i think
uh l-i-p-p-m-a-n-n
and uh he just put out a hundred nfts
with uh bright moments in uh their
berlin show that's going on right now um
i think he deserves a lot more uh
recognition um other other contemporary
artists that are doing fantastic work
let's see off the top of my head uh
let's see sophia crespo is doing really
amazing uh can work
that i think is just a super high
quality
who there's a bunch of uh there's a
bunch of generative artists that uh i
think are already uh uh you know
making amazing work uh dimitri cherniak
and matt delaurier and uh
chettle golid and uh i'm gonna forget
names ben kovach these are all people
from the generative arts team that i've
been watching work for you know five
years or more at this point and they've
been consistently making amazing work
and so i think
that that kind of uh
you want that type of track record you
want to see that the artist has been
serious for for a long time i think
that's a really helpful indicator
you know
i've really that's how you don't get
rugged right yeah that's right like i as
you could tell by my background love
collecting things so i'm a little more
chochkas collectibles comic book sports
cards so as you can imagine the pfp
thing really works for me right yeah so
for me while everyone's chasing the 2021
2022 projects i want to buy plasma bears
like i want to buy you know mooncat i
want to buy like you know
strikers like i like the crypto skulls
like anything pre-2021
it was maybe 2020 was like in between
year but like for me if i find 2019 1817
ethereum projects i get excited
yeah yeah um yeah there's not a there's
not a ton of uh super early uh
generative work i mean uh auto glyphs
are kind of the the classic example but
those things are already crazy expensive
um you know if you want to go og uh the
original some of the earliest generative
art from late 1960s early 1970s is still
massively massively underpriced in my
mind um you can get
amazing work for 10 20 30 thousand
dollars um this is legendary
tell me about that is that uh
is that an nft or is that just digital
art that's just uh
in in most cases this is work that uh
was designed digitally but then plotted
onto paper so they didn't even have uh
normal printers at that point in time
and these artists were working with
plotters which were kind of like a
simple 2d robot you stick a pen in it
and you give it instructions for
something to draw this is how a lot of
generative artists started back in the
day you can get these plotter drawings
still
for
very reasonable prices and um all those
artists had a huge uh influence on
myself and many of the other generative
artists that are working today and tyler
those are those are
framed
framed like on paper
yeah yeah yeah and
and where does one find that ebay or is
that more yeah it's more it's harder
there you you kind of have to like uh
talk to the galleries and and those
types of places so i wish that it was as
simple as nfts that's that's
that's part of i think why nfts uh have
such a big price difference with some of
this traditional work is
it just it's such a better marketplace
like you can see everything that's out
there you can tell exactly what
everybody else is paying and you know
how much they bought it for who owns
what and so it's just so much more
transparent and i think it just makes
for a much healthier marketplace versus
the traditional art world where things
are kind of
locked up and hidden away and sometimes
uh they only sell to specific people you
they won't just sell to any dude who
walks in the door with a you know a bag
of money right so
um yeah i think i think uh
i wish the traditional art world was as
easy to collect as nfts um not yet
though not yet i think they'll i think
they'll figure it out over time now
right because what you're alluding to is
what i'm most excited about in this
whole space which is the nftization
of physical items that sit in
temperature-controlled fireproof houses
and now i'm creating an nft that
represents the physical and if i want
the physical in my apartment i burn the
nft and get it otherwise it just keeps
trading correct
yeah i mean uh debatable about the burn
the nft part i think i think we'll see
multiple different arrangements of how
the nft and the physical are are related
right like whether they're kind of like
legally bound to be together whether
they're allowed to to to kind of be
separate whether you have to pick one or
the other right like there's uh the
damian hurst uh project that's really
interesting called currency so
that was that was on launch where you
made the decision where is what i'm
talking about i'm sorry actually yeah so
so uh damian hurst uh the richest artist
in the world uh right now uh last year
came out with currency right he made
whatever it is three thousand of his
dot paintings they're like this big and
uh
so he sold all the nfts and
uh i think this summer in like a
one-year anniversary uh everybody that
holds the nft has to pick do i want the
nft or do i want the painting right and
it's really really fascinating to see
what happens because
you're literally have the option to have
a painting from like uh the most
successful living artist and i think i
think most people are gonna pick the nft
over the painting that's my guess and
that'll be a really groundbreaking
moment to to really demonstrate um i
think the seriousness of this this new
market um so yeah fascinating project by
damien hurst
yeah i totally agree i think it's
one of the more interesting things going
on in this space um
to me it's the reverse because he
launched it that way everybody knew from
day one you were gonna have a one year
to make a decision burn
or keep right to me what i'm talking
about is my michael jordan rookie card
when i when i sh whatever company or
companies you see where i'm going a
little bit post game my michael jordan
rookie card or for example i'm like
googling as you're talking like i
definitely want to buy some original 60s
generally
out because it's just cool
when i have that if one day in 15 years
i want to send that into
a company that creates an nft that
represents that exact thing yeah yeah
then then i hold the nft then i could
actually trade it like if my friend mike
buys it he might buy it because he
thinks i undersold it yeah but he
doesn't have to take the physical he may
continue to want to trade on it yeah
yeah
yeah
back to your thing on i wish it was as
easy to collect well it can be if a comp
if companies and i believe the future
ebay will be this or ebay has this i
believe much like data centers for
amazon cloud services and all you know
what's happened in your
lifetime yeah because you know a little
bit about enough about tech to know what
i'm saying i actually think we're in the
precipitous of having ungodly amounts of
warehouses built around the world
fireproof and temperature controlled to
take on physical items to issue nfts
that represent that physical item
they're traded the sixth fire gal that
gets the vase
actually wants it in their home thus
they want to call the nft they have to
burn it so it goes off the blockchain to
represent where i'm going yeah and now
it's the vase
and has it and if she seven years later
wants to put it back up she resends it a
new nft is rep and so they're tied
together see what like a motorcycle
yeah i think yeah
no i think you're i think you're right i
think um
uh i think something along those lines
could could could really really happen
and one interesting
element that will probably support this
is uh
you know what's awfully nice about nfts
is it it makes it so much easier to show
your collection off to other people
right so normally like you know i've got
like uh painting on my wall right the
only people that get to see this are
people that physically come to my home
uh when you have this uh digital work
when you have something that's uh
especially in an nft there's so much uh
tooling and platforms to share that work
with other people like
people are are enjoying other people's
uh collections so much more than before
with nfts because it's so much easier to
show off your collection so i think a
lot of physical work will be in a tised
and uh and shown in like you know
virtual galleries uh just because it's
so much easier to to for other people to
enjoy that and
uh you know a few a few people here and
there will be able to see the physical
work but really
uh you know 99 of people are going to be
seeing the work on the internet or
virtual reality or whatever so it makes
more sense to have the work well
documented and well um
you know uh shown in that space uh to me
so talk about the explosion of fidenza a
have the name come up b
your entire nft trajectory like
i love these stories i have a lot of
collectors and i think people will enjoy
like oh you put it out and it was a
dollar and now it's like oh give me that
okay okay uh i'll try to stick to the
facts here okay so early 2021 i done
nothing with with nfts and uh
everybody i know starts dming me saying
you got to get into nfts like this is
this is the jam uh this one and this is
not working every march january yeah
exactly like january february yeah uh
and so uh end of february i see i
apologize real quick i apologize because
this is important context the digital
generative art you were making up to
that point
i was selling that as like unique prints
uh rather than nfts
yeah
prints
so it would do the thing and you would
print it out and sell it yeah exactly
exactly and for everyone's contacts how
much would those be
uh you know those were selling between
uh
at that time like 500 and uh
maybe 2500
something like that
yeah a piece
one of ones or yeah i was doing unique
prints um so regenerative art you know i
can generate multiple images
that's pretty successful yeah for an
artist i was able to support myself uh
full time at that point not not a
luxurious lifestyle or whatever but uh i
was able to eke it out at that point and
it had taken me years and years of work
and building up my my collector base in
order to be able to how much how much
were your original pieces on print going
for
um uh you mean like whenever i first
started the first prince i ever sold
yeah yeah they were like uh like 50 or
100 bucks or something like that so and
where are those and who's got those and
can you send them my yeah i have records
of it um honestly i probably need to
like email some of those people and tell
them to like be careful with their
prints yeah we'll talk offline video
yeah all right
okay okay 2021. uh i've been selling
these prints right uh people are telling
me gotta get into nfts i see um
one of my favorite artists cheddar gola
do
this this project called archetype on
art blocks and i see the dimitri
trainiac has also done ringers on art
blocks and these are amazing projects
and it just i can just tell right away i
need to do this this is this is like
perfect for my work right you see two
other people that you would say you
aspire to be like you feel like like
they're kinship they're your people they
did it i mean ringers is such a
beautiful project and you're like let's
go
absolutely yeah so like uh
that evening i sent in an email to eric
and jeff at art blocks and uh and had
you known snow fro already no i had not
known snow fro apparently he had been
following my work but i didn't know who
he was and uh this was the first i'd
heard of art blocks and so i sent this
email and uh i was like hey i have this
project uh you know it looks it looks
kind of like this i you know uh can i
get in the queue to to be an art blocks
project i'm still going to work on it
some but here's what i've got right now
and uh he emailed me back and he was
like you can't believe you know how
excited i was to to read your email like
let's do this
so i still had to wait in line it was
like three months
until uh
fidenza would launch but i was i was
working every day
just uh really improving it polishing it
doing everything that i could for it
and so
fedenza initially sold so it's 999
iterations 999
uh unique nfts from the same algorithm
so they're related but each one is
different and uh the initial sales price
was like
.17 eth i think um so it was like
something like 400 maybe 450 you can't
remember um and uh
so this this was like
um
going to be by far like the biggest
project i had ever done just just with
those numbers and that was really gonna
you know in my mind help me
get set up as an artist working full
time have a little more financial
security um so everything sold out in
like uh
20 minutes something like that
and uh and then people started getting
uh i think really excited about the work
they started to dig in and one of the
cool things about fidenza is just it has
a lot of variety and a lot of really
interesting uh corners and outliers to
the algorithm so as people started to
look more and more at the output i think
they really started to to understand uh
how generative r could work this way and
and and really get a feel for the
algorithm and so the price just uh it
just started going up and up and then it
you know it was like at some point it
was like doubling every week
um and i mean
the numbers got absolutely crazy they
got crazy there there was one point
where
um
the
you know the floor was like uh i don't
know like almost like 200 eth and uh
i remember like calculating the
valuation and it was like all of fidenza
the valuation the floor evaluation was
like a billion dollars for the whole
algorithm
and uh i was like okay i know this is
like that you know seven eight months
ago was that making you uncomfortable
when they were you know i remember
three thirteen for a thousand a theory
right that's right yeah number three one
three so
a thousand each to uh uh punk six five
two nine hope i got those numbers in the
right order um
and uh yeah i mean it was a it was a
total trip like i felt like i was like
you know alice in wonderland kind of
experience every day uh things were
happening they were just blowing my mind
and of course it felt great but it's
also you know any sort of change is
uncomfortable right even if it's like
positive change and so i could feel that
things were like uh totally shifting
under my feet did you feel pressure do
you like
is there a part of you that likes that
we're in the 40 to 60 range right now um
do you feel like a hair more comfortable
yeah it it it feels more sane it feels
like it has more basis in reality like
in relation to everything else there's
less mania going on right now you know
there was definitely a moment
yeah yeah i think it's a healthier
i want that like uh you know plateau
plateau of productivity and the hype
cycle whatever i think that's what it's
called uh that's where i want to be i i
want people to be making rational
healthy decisions about what to collect
not just uh fomoing into projects you
know
um there were people buying there were
people buying your project that knew
nothing about it i was getting picked by
people they're like should i buy a
fidenza i'm like and literally every
time the first thing i would reply is
what do you know about it right right
yeah
yeah yeah that's that's great advice
like uh don't just don't just like throw
your money at a random project like uh
you know when i collect i collect uh i
collect artists who i know have been
creating high quality work and are like
committed to developing themselves as
artists um and
tyler do you feel pressure to justify
how expensive this [ __ ] is
like are you like [ __ ] this is awesome
[ __ ] to like like you know just getting
a sense of you right
we're going deeper and chopping it up
like is there a part of you that's like
okay um
i
you know this is amazing this is right i
can't believe i can tell my parents
somebody spent three million dollars on
a piece of my art right like my brother
and sister like what the [ __ ] like oh
friends family i'm sure there's all
these like fun stuff but there has to be
nights i mean i feel it with the friends
yeah i'm out here spewing that i'm going
to build wall be walt disney and i'm
like you know i really believe it i
fully expect to do it i'm going to spend
the rest of my life doing it right
but occasionally
in the shower brushing my teeth yeah all
right like this is like a real like it's
not even the walt disney i'm gonna build
disney i actually fully believe that
it's the day in the day out that like
ping
you know my the v friends bought ping
somebody and it says somebody just spent
180 000 on this puffin right and i drew
and i'm like
man i really have you know my brain goes
immediately to i'm gonna [ __ ] kill it
for that puffing yeah do you
yeah i mean i i feel the pressure from
like uh the perspective of i want to
i want to live up to
uh
i guess expectations in a certain way
right like i want i want to make the
best artwork that i can at this point
it's really
helped me to raise the bar for the type
of work that uh i'll produce now you
know i take take it very seriously um
but
on the other
uh hands i i know that i have to divorce
myself from the market and that the
market doesn't
uh doesn't reflect like the quality of
the work right like fidenza sold at one
value at one time they sold for a
different value at a different time and
now they sell it another value and it's
the exact same work um so clearly
there's like some disconnect between the
market and the quality of work right and
i think as well as the artist like to
let yourself sleep at night just like uh
you got to be more hands off from that
that's what i tell every founder of
every pfp project i'm like if you listen
to your discord and you care about the
floor price your data reliable yeah yeah
most definitely most definitely like
that's not that's not where your head
should be at as the artist like that's
that's not how you create good work
that's not how you do your best work
that's not how you do the best um
make the best choices for your
collectors either you know i think you
have to uh think long term and um and
and and really make uh ethical and
intelligent decisions about what you're
doing
you're here to that are you working on
more stuff now oh god am i working first
yeah the most stuff i've ever worked on
at once um
lots of cool projects and will these
projects have different names like
you know people refer to you as vadenza
now
yeah yeah
are you gonna keep that as your kind of
monarchy or you
know that's just one project and uh yeah
you asked me to explain the name and i i
accidentally glossed over that i was
trying to pick a name for the for the
work and uh sometimes i like to pick
things that don't have a real strong
inherent meaning and so sometimes i use
town names oftentimes small texas town
names i was looking around for one in
texas that fit and nothing quite did so
i went in google maps over to italy and
i was kind of panning around and this
little town
25 000 people
called vadenza just stood out to me as a
cool name i was like wow okay i'm going
to call this project for denzel so
that's what that one was but every work
every algorithm gets uh gets a new name
and uh before before i die i'm making
this promise to myself before i die
hopefully in 55 years i
i
am going to buy a fidenza
while i'm infidenza yeah yeah
you know uh the the mayor
the mayor fidenza dm to me on twitter so
i can i can help you set that up yeah
yeah yeah where is it
it's like it's like northern italy it's
like three
hours north of rome it's it's kind of in
the middle of nowhere it's like there's
literally not that much
so what you literally are google mapping
yeah you're looking at names you like
the name you zoom in you make sure that
you kind of get a little like vibe for
it yeah
that's funny yeah cool yeah yeah i mean
it's it's not like a special town you
know it's just some town uh you know art
art really
excites me i i've re this has been such
a profound moment in my life you know i
had so much more of it in me than i ever
showed the world right
but if you really peeled the onion it
was there
i'll give you an example i don't know
what about you doing google map vedenza
work made me just think about i
literally was talking to somebody just
now earlier this morning
and realized i love optimism more than
anything yeah
which led me to say wait a minute i have
not done enough character development
around the optimistic otter and be
friends yeah and like literally like
have been for like the last two hours
while i'm doing this podcast and
thinking about my meetings and thinking
about what i have to do there's like
three percent of my brain that is
working right now that i can feel that
is ideating on how i have to make the
optimistic otter a more important
character in defense from a creative
artistic lens yeah yeah what is what is
the otter going to do who's the otters
it's going to be am i going to make it a
cartoon do i make that a video game like
i love
creation
yeah by the way how does it feel for you
to to be an artist now do you think of
yourself as an artist
you know i used to always think of
entrepreneurship as art like i i really
think being an entrepreneur is
incredibly artistic yeah yeah you're a
poor bred entrepreneur you adore artists
because you know your your your
creativity your lack of fear if you're
pure
like the problem with entrepreneurship
is there's money right what's also about
art is like starving artists is romantic
and respected the tough part of being an
artistic entrepreneur
is the money part clouds it and it can
look dark but it's much a pure game of
art yeah yeah the motivation for the
person running it if they're doing it
well they almost certainly don't just
care about the money right like i think
or they barely care about the money
right like that's just a weird place
where it's it's outside collateral noise
to the process yeah yeah i'm aware of it
i'm grateful for it it's not like i'm
not demonizing it like i love it for
people for me
it's all about freedom which i don't
think is just predicated about money
right uh but of course money is one of
the pillars of freedom depending on how
one looks at the world
i just like being artistic yeah yeah and
and it seems like
you're thinking deeply about uh at least
the motivations for what you're doing
right like optimistic otter right like
uh i love that we need more optimism
why why
when i like really i've been saying it
but only a few people are paying
attention they okay a million that's a
lot less than 8 billion when the world
realizes what i'm actually [ __ ] doing
with this project
i'm very excited about
the positivity and practicality that i'm
going to bring into the world because of
it yeah yeah
i mean i think that's super important i
think that's super important um i've
gotta run to something ironically in
befriend's land i'm starting to cut
surprises
part two but you're fantastic i'm
cheering for you heavy and uh if i could
ever be helped please let me thank you
so much gary yeah likewise likewise uh
it's been a real pleasure thanks brother
take care you too